هو واحد من أغنى أغنياء
الروس الذين أدانوا علنًا حرب أوكرانيا
، الملياردير الذي أسس Tink off
Bank وهو أحد أكبر المقرضين في روسيا والذي تخلى الآن
عن جنسيته الروسية
صفعة كبيرة على وجه الكرملين
نشر وثيقة الإنهاء
على الإنترنت جنبًا إلى جنب مع لاذع  انتقادات
للدولة الروسية لا أستطيع ولن أكون
مرتبطة ببلد
فاشي كتب تينكوف على صفحته على إنستغرام
دولة بدأت حربًا بطبيعتها
السلمية وذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك داعياً
الأثرياء الروس الآخرين لمغادرة
البلاد أيضًا  خلف ،
آمل أن يتابعني رجال أعمال روس بارزون ،
لذا فإن ذلك يضعف
نظام بوتين واقتصاده ويضعه في نهاية المطاف في طريق
هزيمة المنصب ، وسرعان ما تم حذف هذا المنصب ، وهو ما
يلقي تينكوف باللوم على متصيدي الكرملين في
المرة الأولى التي انتقد فيها تينكوف بوتين وصراعه الأوكراني علنًا
ولكن
يبدو أن مشاهد العنف
وأهواله هذه شبه اليومية قد دفعت الملياردير
إلى العودة  في مايو ، تحدث تينكوف الذي يعاني من
مرض السرطان عن كيف أن معركته من أجل
البقاء جعلت من المستحيل البقاء
صامتًا في مواجهة الكثير من القتل ،
فقد التقط مقطع الفيديو
أطفالًا نساءً يموتون من أجل لا
شيء يقتلهم شخص ما
، أعني أن الجيش الروسي يقتلهم
من أجل لا شيء يمكن أن تموت من السرطان ، ولكن
لماذا تموت من قنبلة
لمجرد أنك تعيش في أوكرانيا ، فهذا أمر
خاطئ خاصة في القرن الحادي والعشرين ،
فأنت تدفع هذا الدين بالطبع ، كان
هناك مليارديرات روس آخرون بارزون
انتقدوا
حرب أوكرانيا  حتى oligarapaska أحد أقطاب المعادن
المعروف بأنه قريب من بوتين
وصفه بأنه خطأ فادح على الرغم
من عدم إلقاء اللوم على
الكرملين ضائعًا من فضلك ، وفي وقت سابق من هذا الشهر
قال مستثمر ملياردير آخر يوري ميلنر
إنه تخلى عن جوازات سفره الروسية التي
شوهدت هنا في لندن
حيث على الرغم من البريطانيين.  العقوبات التي لا يزال
يقضيها معظم وقته تقول إنه
التقى ببوتين مرة واحدة فقط لتناول الجعة منذ أكثر من
20 عامًا ، لكنه يقول إنه  tes
روسيا بوتين وهو الآن
ينأى بنفسه عنها جميعًا بسبب ما
يسميه خير حرب بوتين المجنونة